the insanity of Gojo and tsukuna
continues and it looks like it all comes
down to a few moments as we'll see so
make sure to stay tuned for this epic
chapter smash that like button if you
enjoy seeing these weekly Jujutsu Kaizen
reviews on the channel and want to keep
them coming join the special great fam
if you haven't already by subscribing
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications so you don't
miss future Jutsu Kai's and videos and
updates and now without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all so
the chapter itself starts with a high
question with the question of who here
has ever been seriously punched by Gojo
I like how Panda says he seriously
punched Gojo before but didn't end up
touching him of course the very strong
hakari and special grade Utah are the
only ones who Gojo actually did
seriously punch and if you remember
these two have the potential to rival
Gojo's power one day according to Gojo
so it's not surprising that he'd only
serious punch the best sounds like I'm
talking about one punch man now but
anyways Utah even says if by seriously
punched you mean taking a blow from his
Limitless technique that I have Gojo's
this enhanced with curse energy and at
the moment of impact blue repeatedly
absorbs the surrounding space hakere is
the one who says that doesn't just make
Gojo's punches stronger it feels like
you've been clocked by a counter-attack
after preparing for a regular blow he
says it's the absolute worst when asked
a seemingly ridiculous question whether
or not it hurt they both look down
sweating and say it made them puke Yuji
points out that my boy nalami had
mentioned something about that as well
he said to Yuji if he intends on
continuing as a sorcerer he should make
a point of not comparing himself to Gojo
he said Gojo is able to produce Critical
Hits as if they're your run-of-the-mill
jab while none of me struggled to
perform them in the first place he told
Yuji to put it bluntly nobody can keep
up with Gojo kusakabe says what he's
trying to say is that from here on out
he doesn't have a clue what Gojo's doing
so don't ask for me that whole section
of the chapter pumped up how strong
Gojo's punches are and how strong sukuna
is for being able to take them but more
importantly hopefully it's building up
for helping to explain how Gojo will end
sukuna with a single one of these insane
critical hit punches we then see Gojo
going ham he looks like a kid in a candy
store with a big smile spread across his
face it's hilarious sukuna is getting
hurt punch after punch while Gojo is
smiling the whole time loving light
right now Gojo definitely looks in
control but we know in this fight how
quickly that can change he's hitting
sukuna and when not sukuna is dodging
him then from the looks of it Gojo is
moving so fast he's creating after
images yet sukuna still manages after
taking all that damage to grab Gojo's
Fist and to throw a punch himself love
how Gojo just says whoopsie while still
smiling he blocks the punch with his own
hand but you can tell how much force it
carried from the manga panel as Gojo's
face is pushed back a lot even though
his hand is in front of his face now in
retrospect that did also look like the
Clone technique that we saw from the bag
mask curse user during the Gojo
flashback and Gojo was impressed by this
technique but just not by the user so it
could be possible that he learned to do
it somehow or like I said it was just
moving quickly but it would be a little
disappointing if he did learn to use
that technique that he hyped up and then
it was literally over in like a second
and it didn't accomplish anything so let
me know if you think it was actually
just moving fast or a clone technique
but Gojo really is just like a kid
having fun and he moves from this attack
to back flipping and landing on a
traffic light this must be the most fun
Gojo has had since toji pushed him to
evolve to the next level however in that
fight he easily won after he did evolve
well here he has evolved and is still
able to go full out so I think he's
having the most fun ever probably then
something is mentioned that shouldn't be
surprising since I spoke about it in the
last chapter review it said the word
treasure used in the Chant to manifest
mahoraga along with that wheel
represents complete circulation and
Harmony once maharaga has been attacked
the wheel turns starting the adaptation
we see the wheel spinning above sukuna
it's noted that it's spinning and the
question is raised did he adapt already
now go Mojo has noticed that when
tsukune uses domain amplification to be
able to touch Gojo the wheel turns black
so he thinks to himself that it's safe
to assume that it interrupts any
adaptation process so you can't activate
his domain but he can use amplification
probably because the area of the brain
that Gojo hit was in charge of barrier
techniques and then tsukuna for his part
thinks to himself in order to avoid the
adaptation he isn't using anything aside
from his curse technique lapse well
that's to be expected then I really like
this part we see what looks like the
street light changing and I'm guessing
it's changing into green to signify go
and the Fight Continues again that's
awesome cinematography and I think
that's gonna be awesome when animated I
can tell the authors having a lot of fun
with this fight as well just like Gojo
is the Fight Continues and sukuna is now
using a street light as a weapon and
throwing it at Gojo I suppose this can
also be a way to combat Gojo's blue
attraction technique so that he has to
deal with the street lights before he
can deliver a hit on sukuna then it's
pointed out that sukuna isn't bringing
out maharaga and it's a assume that it's
because it's adapted to unlimited void
five times hakari asks if that means
that it needs to turn several times in
order to adapt to Gojo's Limitless
technique and it's pointed out that it's
possible considering how little regard
those two have for what's impossible and
I like the way that was phrased now the
two fighters who couldn't go to our
chill again for a minute before the
Fight Continues again Gojo says you need
four spins total yeah that leaves three
more three more spins of the wheel until
maharaga adapts to Gojo's infinity and
everyone's like yo panicked exclamation
marks everywhere because they don't
think that's much even Yuji is like just
three spins left tsukuna laughs saying
looks like we have ourselves a countdown
to when the smirk will be wiped off your
face that is and Gojo smiles back
hilariously saying right back at you
with a great big smile on his face he
says I'll beat you dead before you even
hit three spins and again I love seeing
Gojo having so much fun it's one of my
favorite aspects of this fight for sure
then comes another hilarious moment
Hannah asks Gojo hasn't forgotten about
megumi has he and Yoshi replies he might
have since Gojo seems so lost in the joy
of the fight right now I remember
reading one comment saying Gojo is far
stronger and sukuna had to rely on
megumi and maharaga to stand a chance
and although that's a good point it
remains that sukuna had the power to do
that and because of that I don't think
we can really hold it against them the
dude is good at strategizing and it's
within his powers so still it makes for
an interesting fight nonetheless but now
we finally know that this most epic of
Epic fights is about to end and that's
all we had to hear for every next
chapter and move to be more intense
because as the narrator tells us at the
end of the chapter the deadly claw
countdown has begun and giving a
countdown like that is always a way to
build intensity another epic chapter of
the most epic fight and as I thought
mahuraga's adaptation ability would be
an important factor and of course it was
I obviously want Gojo to win because
he's Gojo he's hype and I like the
character more but you gotta admit it
will kill a lot of the drama if gold
Mojo gets the W without even dying and
tsukuna is gone as a threat so I feel
like if anything Gojo might actually be
in trouble from a storytelling
perspective but we'll see what happens
let me know if you think we'll make it
to three spins or if you think Gojo will
win before that what does seem pretty
clear though is that both of these guys
have probably never been in a more
difficult fight that is hype in and of
itself and I'm hoping it means we'll get
to see everything each one has under
their sleeves before it's over so can't
wait for that can't wait to learn more
about these already super strong
characters and their strongest moves if
you enjoyed this review and want to keep
them coming you know what to do smash
that like button with no mercy if you
haven't joined the special grade fam by
subscribing hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications so you
don't miss future Jujutsu Kaizen videos
like this one and as always place your
bets as your opinion changed who will
win the fight Gojo or tsukuna place your
bets in the comments below But You Gotta
Give it to sukuna he's a very strong and
good but not the final villain if you
want to know who that is check out our
new video yuji's mom is the final
villain link on screen right now and
I'll see you there